in diesem moment
demonstranten zu aufständischen votierte
der protest zum umsturzversuch angeführt
von mitgliedern der
rechtsextremistischen kraut boys are
back die gitter vielen und die menschen
flotten hinein die wasser das sich
überall hin ausbreitet
westedt war mitten drin weil der
journalist engen zugang gefunden hatte
zu den milizionären wir treffen ihn in
new york erzählt vom vorabend des 6
januar als sich die chefs zweier milizen
in einer tiefgarage besprachen ein
exklusives zeitzeugnis denn auf keepers
unkraut boys wollten dafür sorgen dass
donald trump präsidenten
sie sagten die ort keepers und hip hop
boys hätten zwar immer schon
unterschiedliche konzepte und
vorgehensweisen gehabt aber sie seien
jetzt brüder im gemeinsamen kampf und
müssten in diesem moment
zusammenarbeiten
deshalb lud der untersuchungsausschuss
nick als ersten zeugen die abgeordneten
allen voran auch die republikanerin des
chaney sehen es als erwiesen dass die
extremisten auf bitte von donald trump
den umsturz planten chaney stellt sich
entschieden gegen die führung ihrer
eigenen partei die milizionäre wollten
offenbar bürogebäude und das kapitol
besetzen überwachungsfotos zeigen wie
sie in einem hotel in virginia
washington waffen bereit legten für den
krieg gegen parasiten
genau dass krieg die in die parasiten
ruft nämlich ein als die braut boys am 6
januar losmarschieren zur überraschung
von nick festival um 10 uhr 30 also vor
trumps rede am weißen haus
gegen mittag entfesseln sie die gewalt
gegen eine völlig unterbesetzte polizei
ihre wortwahl änderte sich zu folgt
eurem ihr verräter sie griffen die
polizei an was sie vorher nie getan hat
bis dahin waren sie immer die
unterstützer der polizei weckte blumen
sie es das war vorbei jetzt hieß es du
bist ein verräter
[Applaus]
der lärm der wut ohrenbetäubend
alle hemmungen das belegt das
filmmaterial sind gefallen
mordlust liegt in der luft
[Applaus]
offenbar geteilt von ihrem anstifter
[Musik]
als der präsident hörte dass die
aufständischen mike pence hängen wollten
antwortete er vielleicht haben unsere
unterstützer den richtigen gedanken mike
pence verdient es
so viele menschenverachtung könnte
zumindest einige wechselwähler
beeindrucken so dass sie bei den
kongresswahlen im november für die
demokraten stimmen auch weil selbst
drums engstes umfeld ihn als lügner
entlarvt
ich hielt nichts von der idee dass die
ral gestohlen sagte den präsidenten das
ist pech
so sah es auch trance tochter ich
respektiere justiz
also akzeptierte ich was er sagte
trotzdem lockt er weiter dass sich die
balken bogen und fasste damit die wut an
die sich am 6 januar in gewalt entladen
wird
ich war recht demoralisiert dachte junge
wenn er das wirklich glaubt hat er den
bezug zur realität verloren
viele extra mwp berater sehen es genauso
nur die parteiführung verschließe weiter
die augen solist chain
ich sage zu meinen republikanischen
kollegen die das verteidigen was nicht
zu verteidigen ist irgendwann es donald
trump weg aber eure ehelosigkeit wird
bleiben
aber aufständische wir ein kelly werden
in der republikanischen partei sogar
belohnt obwohl er dafür jetzt angeklagt
wird tritt der republikaner als
gouverneurskandidat in michigan dabei
gewesen zu sein ist so etwas wie ein
ehrenabzeichen
sprungbrett für die karriere braut bei
christa sängers wurde zusammen mit
weiteren extremisten in den
exekutivausschuss der republikaner im
landkreis miami gewählt die partei im
griff der braut boys titelte die new
york times
eine trumps muss welle rollt durchs land
meint professor goldstone bei den
vorwahlen der republikanischen partei
auch diese woche setzten sich meist
kandidaten durch die wahllüge befreit im
herbst könnten sie gouverneure
innenminister und abgeordnete werden
je mehr die partei dass extremistische
pro trump amerika in ihrer führung
akzeptiert desto geringer wird der
einfluss von liz cheney die ja schon
exkommuniziert ist es ist fast ein
wettbewerb wer der größte trump
unterstützer ist die große lüge am
lautesten verbreitet und wer den meisten
extremismus zeigt wie extremer du bist
in der jetzigen republikanischen partei
desto besser
das ermutigt auch extremisten im ganzen
land braut boys stürmten am wochenende
eine drag-queen veranstaltung in san
francisco in idaho entdeckte die polizei
31 mitglieder der rechtsextremistischen
patriot front die eine lgbt kyu parade
aufmischen wollten zwar ohne waffen aber
mit handgreiflicher gewalt
ich sorge mich dass politiker 2022 oder
24 ihren anhängern hinterher sagen dass
ihm die weise stolen wurde sie werden
trump nachmachen und das wird ähnliche
folgen haben wir sind weiterhin sehr
großer gefahr
auch nick westedt hält weitere gewalt
für möglich denn die wut vom 6 januar
nach
ob die braut boys haben seitdem dreimal
mehr mitglieder als vorher und neue
ortsgruppen in ganz amerika
das interessierte mich ob sie eher wie
die jakobiner der französischen
revolution sind oder wie faschisten oder
die fußball hooligans sie sind eine
kombination aus allen dreien und das was
sie zusammenhält ist der tourismus ein
paar anführer der milizen sind zwar
jetzt im gefängnis aber dieser sturm war
vielleicht nur der probelauf für das was
noch kommt
[Applaus]